does it worry you
a future where we have increasingly
higher autonomy in our weapon systems in
our war so you said building
what
about uh telling a set of
fully autonomous drones to get rid of
all the terrorists in the city
so these multiple buildings
region
that kind of that's a greater and
greater um
autonomy
so that that's a fear right um
you're viewing it from we can cover more
perspective which is um
fair and
a lot of we i i don't approach it from
that topic at least i don't think of it
that way at least morally
um
i think that with the advancement of
warfare assuming we have a justin and
moral leadership
uh if that's the case then
i am an advocate for increased autonomy
and technology because i see it as an
ability to be more precise
and if we trust the moral leadership of
our
government then we would want to be as
precise as possible in order to mitigate
effects that we don't want
so
i know that's not a satisfying answer
and it leaves us well no bad feelings
but no because having experienced sort
of um
directly seen
what it looks like
when deliberately or
carelessly
leads to the death of a large number of
civilians as it does in currently in
ukraine
the the value of precision
uh given ethical leadership becomes
apparent
so there's something
distinctly unethical about the the
murder of civilians in a time of war
um and i think technology helps lessen
that
of course all death is is terrible
but there's there's something about um
schools hospitals
being destroyed with everybody inside
being killed um
yeah it's particularly terrible
it is
and you know you approached it from the
angle of more autonomy enables a wider
you know swath of destruction and
that's where we get back into you know
who who's making the decisions based off
of this and
you know my hope again would be that we
would have the leadership that would use
these things when needed in the precise
way as possible to minimize that and
i've seen that firsthand you know i've
seen that in country i've seen
not not blue forces but you know i've
seen truck bombs go off on school buses
you know driving around afghanistan
uh
while escorting convoys and you know it
wasn't easy then and i'm sure it's not
any easier now especially after what
you've just seen
you